John by the grace of God King of England
rule of Ireland Duke of Normandy and
Aquitaine and count of Anjou twos
Archbishop's bishops Abbot's Earl's
barons justices of foresters sheriffs
stewards servants and to all his
officials and loyal subjects greeting
know that before God for the health of
our soul and those of our ancestors and
heirs to the honour of God the
exaltation of the Holy Church and the
better ordering of our kingdom at the
advice of our Reverend father's stephen
archbishop of canterbury by marte of all
england and cardinal of the holy roman
church henry archbishop of dublin
william bishop of london peter bishop of
winchester jocelyn bishop of bath and
glastonbury hugh Bishop of Lincoln
walter bishop of worcester william
bishop of coventry benedict Bishop of
Rochester master pandulf subdeacon and
member of the papal household brother
aymeric master of the knighthood of the
temple in england William Marshall earl
of pembroke william earl of salisbury
william earl of warren william earl of
arundel alan of galloway constable of
scotland waren
fitzgerald peter fitz herbert hubert de
burgh seneschal of poitou ah hugh de
neville matthew fitz herbert thomas
basset alan basset philip Durbin II
Robert - rah polly john marshall john
fitz hugh and other loyal subjects
[Music]
first that we have granted to God and by
this present charter have confirmed for
us and our heirs in perpetuity that the
English church shall be free and shall
have its rights undiminished and its
liberties unimpaired that we wish this
so to be observed appears from the fact
of our own free will
before the outbreak of the present
dispute between us and our barons we
granted and confirmed by charter the
freedom of the churches elections a
right reckoned to be of the greatest
necessity and importance to it and cause
this to be confirmed by Pope Innocent
the third this freedom we shall observe
ourselves and desire to be observed in
good faith by our heirs in perpetuity to
all freemen of our kingdom we have also
granted for us and our heirs forever all
the liberties written out below to have
and to keep for them and their heirs of
us and our heirs if any Earl Baron or
other person that holds lands directly
of the crown for military service shall
die and at his death his heir shall be
of full age and Oh a relief the heir
shall have his inheritance on payment of
the ancient scale of relief that is to
say the heir or heirs of an Earl shall
pay one hundred pounds for the entire
Earl's barony the heir or heirs of a
knight one hundred shillings at most for
the entire Knights fee and any man that
owes less shall pay less in accordance
with the ancient usage of fees but if
the heir of such a person is under age
and award when he comes of age he shall
have his inheritance without relief or
fine the guardian of the land of an heir
who is under age shall take it from it
only reasonable revenues customary dues
and feudal services he shall do this
without destruction or damage to men or
property if we have given the
guardianship of the land to a sheriff or
to any person answerable to us for the
revenue
use and he commits destruction or damage
we will exact compensation from him and
the land shall be entrusted to two
worthy and prudent men of the same fee
who shall be answerable to us for the
revenues or to the person to whom we
haven't signed them if we have given or
sold to anyone the guardianship of such
land and he causes destruction or damage
he shall lose the guardianship of it and
it shall be handed over to two worthy
and prudent men of the same three who
shall be similarly answerable to us for
so long as a guardian has guardianship
of such land he shall maintain the
houses parks fish preserves ponds mills
and everything else pertaining to it
from the revenues of the land itself
when the air comes average he shall
restore the whole land to him stocked
with plow teams and such implements of
husbandry as the season demands and the
revenues from the land can reasonably
bear heirs may be given in marriage but
not someone of lower social standing
before a marriage takes place it shall
be made known to the heirs next of kin
at her husband's death a widow may have
her marriage portion and inheritance at
once and without trouble she shall pay
nothing for her dower
marriage portion or any inheritance that
she and her husband held jointly on the
day of his death she may remain in her
husband's house for forty days after his
death and within this period her dower
shall be assigned to her no Widow shall
be compelled to marry so long as she
wishes to remain without a husband but
she must give security that she will not
marry without royal consent if she holds
her lands of the crown or without the
consent of whatever other law she may
hold them off neither we nor our
officials will seize any land or rent in
payment of a debt so long as the debtor
has movable goods sufficient to
discharge the debt a debtors sureties
shall not be distrained upon so long as
the debtor himself can discharge his day
if for lack of means the debtor is
unable to discharge his debt
his sureties shall be answerable for it
if they so desire they may have the
debtors lands and rents until they have
received satisfaction for the debt that
they paid for him unless the debtor can
show that he settled his obligations to
them if anyone who has borrowed a sum of
money from Jews dies before the debt has
been repaid his heir shall pay no
interest on the debt for so long as he
remains underage irrespective of whom he
holds his lands if such a debt falls
into the hands of the crown it will take
nothing except the principle some
specified in the bond if a man dies
owing money to Jews his wife may have
heard our and paying nothing towards the
dead from it if he leaves children that
are underage their needs may also be
provided for on a scale appropriate to
the size of his holding of lands the
debt is to be paid out of the residue
reserving the service due to his feudal
lords debts owed to persons other than
Jews are to be dealt with similarly no
scooted or aid may be levied in our
kingdom without its general consent
unless it is for the ransom our person
to make our eldest son a knight and once
to marry our eldest daughter for these
purposes only a reasonable aid may be
levied aids from the City of London are
to be treated similarly the City of
London shall enjoy all its ancient
liberties and free customs both by land
and by water we also will and grant that
all other cities boroughs towns and
ports shall enjoy all their liberties
and free customs to obtain the general
consent of the realm for the assessment
of an aide except in three cases
specified above or a scooted we will
cause the Archbishop's bishops Abbot's
Earl's and greater barons
to be summoned individually by letter to
those who hold vans directly of us we
will cause a general summons to be
issued through the sheriff's and other
officials to come together on a fixed
day of which at least forty days notice
shall be given
and at a fixed place in all letters of
summons the cause of the summons will be
stated when a summons has been issued
the business appointed for the day shall
go forward in accordance with the
resolution of those present even if not
all those who were summoned have
appeared in future we will allow no man
to levy an aid from his free man except
to ransom his person to make his eldest
son a knight and once to marry his
eldest daughter for these purposes only
a reasonable aid may be levied no man
shall be forced to perform more service
for a knight's fee or other free holding
of land then is due from it
ordinary lawsuits shall not follow the
royal court around but shall be held in
a fixed place inquests of novel
disseisin
Maud ancestor and darien presentment
shall be taken only in their proper
county court
we ourselves or in our absence abroad
our chief justice will send two justices
to each County four times a year and
these justices with four Knights of the
county elected by the county itself
shall hold the Assizes in the county
court on the day and in the place where
the court meets if any Assizes cannot be
taken on the day of the county court as
many Knights and freeholders shall
afterwards remain behind of those who
have attended the court as will suffice
for the administration of justice having
regard to the volume of business to be
done if any Assizes cannot be taken on
the day of the county court as many
Knights and freeholders shall afterwards
remain behind of those who have attended
the court as will suffice for the
administration of justice having regard
to the volume of business to be done
for a trivial offense a free man shall
be fined only in proportion to the
degree of his offense and her serious
offense correspondingly but not so heavy
as to deprive him of his livelihood in
the same way a merchant shall be spared
his merchandise and a villain the
implements of his husbandry if they fall
upon the mercy of a royal court
none of these fines shall be imposed
except by the assessment on oath of
reputable men of the neighborhood Earl's
and barons shall be fined only by their
equals and in proportion to the gravity
of their offence a fine imposed upon the
lay property of a clerk in holy orders
shall be assessed upon the same
principles without reference to the
value of his ecclesiastical benefice no
town or person shall be forced to build
bridges over rivers except those with an
ancient obligation to do so no sheriff
constable coroners nor other royal
officials are to hold lawsuits that
should be held by the Royal justices
every county hundred wipin take and
tithing shall remain at its ancient rent
without increase except the royal
demesnes manors if at the death of a man
who holds a lay fee of the crown a
sheriff or royal office produces royal
letters patent of summons for debt due
to the crown it shall be lawful for them
to cease Analysts
movable goods found in the layfie of the
dead man to the value of the debt as
assessed by worthy man nothing shall be
removed until the whole debt is paid
when the residue shall be given over to
the executors to carry out the dead
man's will if no debt is due to the
crown all the movable goods shall be
regarded as the property of the dead man
except the reasonable shares of his wife
and children if a free man dies
intestate his movable goods are to be
distributed by his
next of kin and friends under the
supervision of the church the rights of
his debtors are to be preserved no
constable or other royal office shall
take corn or other movable goods from
any man without immediate payment unless
the seller voluntarily offers
postponement of this no constable may
compel a knight to pay money for castle
guard if the knight is willing to
undertake the guard in person all with
reasonable excused supply some other fit
man to do it
a knight taken or sent on military
service shall be excused from castle
guard for the period of his service no
Sheriff royal official or other person
shall take horses or carts for transport
from any free man without his consent
neither we nor any royal official will
take wood for our Castle or offer any
other purpose without the consent of the
owner we will not keep the lands of
people convicted of felony in our hands
for longer than a year and a day after
which they shall be returned to the
Lords of the fees concerned all fish
wares shall be removed from the thames
the Medway and throughout the whole of
England except on the sea coast the writ
called presip II shall not in future be
issued to anyone in respect of any
holding of land if a free man could
thereby be deprived of the right of
trial in his own lands court there shall
be standard measures of wine ale and
corn the London quota throughout the
kingdom there shall also be a standard
width of dyed cloth russet and have
eject they need to elves within the
salvages weights are to be standardized
similarly in future nothing shall be
paid or accepted for the issue of a writ
of Inquisition of life or limbs it shall
be given gratis and not refused
if a man holds land of the crown by
fee-farm socage or burgage and also
holds lands of somebody else for Knights
service we will not have guardianship of
his heir nor the land that belongs to
the other person's fee by virtue of the
fee-farm socage or burgage unless the
fee-farm owes knight's service we will
not have the guardianship of a man's air
or of land that he holds of someone else
by reason of any small property that he
may hold of the crown for a service of
knives arrows or the like in future no
officials shall place a man on trial
upon his own unsupported statement
without producing credible witnesses to
the truth of it no free man shall be
seized or imprisoned or stripped of his
rights or possessions or outlawed or
exiled or deprived of his standing in
any way nor will we proceed with force
against him or send others to do so
except by the lawful judgment of his
equals or
by the law of the land to no one will we
sell to no one deny or delay right to
justice all merchants may enter or leave
England unharmed and without fear and
may stay or travel within it by land or
water for purposes of trade free from
all legal exactions in accordance with
ancient and lawful customs this however
does not apply in time of war to
merchants from a country that is at war
with us any such merchants found in our
country at the outbreak of war shall be
detained without injury to their persons
or property until we or our chief
justice have discovered how our own
merchants are being treated in the
country at war with us if our own
merchants are safe they shall be safe -
in future it shall be lawful for any man
to leave and return to our kingdom
unharmed and without fear by land or
water preserving his allegiance to us
except in time of war for some short
period for the common benefit of the
people that have been imprisoned or
outlawed in accordance with the law of
the land people from a country that is
at war with us and merchants who shall
be dealt with as stated above are
accepted from this provision if a man
holds lands of any
isquite such as the honor of Wallingford
Nottingham Boulogne Lancaster or other s
Keats in our hand that our baron ease at
his death his heir shall give us only
the relief and service that he would
have made to the baron and the barony
being in the Barons hand we will hold
the Eschete in the same manner as the
baron held it people who live outside
the forest need not in future appear
before the Royal justices of the forest
in answer to general summonses unless
they are actually involved in
proceedings or are surtees for someone
who has been seized for a forest offense
we will appoint as justices constables
sheriff's or other officials only men
that know the law of the realm and are
minded to keep it well all barons who
have founded Abbey's and have charters
of English kings or ancient tenure as
evidence of this may have guardianship
of them when there is no abbot as is
there do all forests that have been
created in our reign shall at once be
dis are forested riverbanks that have
been enclosed in our reign shall be
treated similarly all evil customs
relating to forests and warrens
foresters warren Asst sheriffs and their
servants or river banks and their
wardens are at once to be investigated
in every county by 12 sworn knights of
the county and within forty days of
their inquiry the evil customs are to be
abolished completely and irrevocably but
we or our Chief Justice if we are not in
England are first to be informed we will
at once return all hostages and charters
delivered up to us by Englishmen as
security for peace or
full loyal service we will remove
completely from their offices the
kinsmen of Gerard DRC and in future they
shall hold no offices in England the
people in question are angle and Tessa
Gagne Peter guy and Andrew - and so died
Sigourney Jeffrey de martini and his
brothers Philip mark and his brothers
with Jeffrey his nephew and all their
followers as soon as peace is restored
we will remove from the kingdom all the
foreign Knights bowmen their attendants
and the mercenaries that have come to
its harm with horses and arms to any man
whom we have deprived or dispossessed of
lands castles liberties or rights
without the lawful judgement of his
equals we will at once restore these in
cases of dispute the matter shall be
resolved by the judgment of the
twenty-five barons referred to below in
the clause for securing the peace in
cases however where a man was deprived
or dispossessed of something without the
lawful judgment of his equals by our
Father King Henry or our brother King
Richard and it remains in our hands or
is held by others under our warranty we
shall have respite for the period
commonly allowed to Crusaders a lesser
lawsuit had been begun or an inquiry had
been made at our order before we took
the cross as a crusader on our return
from the crusade if we abandon it we
will at once render justice in full we
shall have similar respite in rendering
justice in connection with forests that
are to be disappear stood or to remain
forests when these were first afforested
by our Father Henry or our brother
Richard with the guardianship of lands
in another person's fee when we have
hitherto had this by virtue of a fee
held the bus for knight's service by a
third party and with Abbey's founded in
another person's fee in which the lord
of the fee claims to own a right on our
return from the crusade or if we abandon
it we will at once do full justice to
complaints about these matters
no one shall be arrested or imprisoned
on the appeal of a woman for the death
of any person except her husband all
fines that have been given to us
unjustly and against the law of the land
and all fines that we have exacted
unjustly shall be entirely remitted or
the matter decided by a majority
judgment of the twenty-five barons
referred to below in the clause for
securing the peace together with Stephen
Archbishop of Canterbury if he can be
present and such others as he wishes to
bring with him if the archbishop cannot
be present proceedings shall continue
without him provided that if any of the
twenty-five barons has been involved in
a similar suit himself his judgment
shall be set aside and someone else
chosen and sworn in his place as a
substitute for the single occasion by
the rest of the twenty-five if we have
deprived or dispossessed any Welshman of
land liberties or anything else in
England or in Wales
without the lawful judgment of their
equals these are at once to be returned
to them a dispute on this point shall be
determined in the Marches by the
judgement of equals English law shall
apply to holdings of land in England
Welsh law to those in Wales and the law
of the Marches to those in the Marches
the Welsh shall treat us and ours in the
same way in cases where a Welshman was
deprived or dispossessed of anything
without the lawful judgment of his
equals by our father King Henry or our
brother King Richard and it remains in
our hands or is held by others under our
warranty we shall have respite for the
period commonly allowed to Crusaders
unless a lawsuit had been begun or an
inquiry had been made at our order
before we took the cross as a Crusader
but on our return from the crusade or if
we abandon it we will at once do full
justice according to the laws of Wales
and the said regions we will at once
return the son of Llewellyn all Welsh
hostages and the charters delivered to
us as security for the peace with regard
to the return of the sisters and us
years of Alexander King of Scotland his
liberties and his rights we will treat
him in the same way as our other barons
of England unless it appears from the
charters that we hold from his father
William formerly King of Scotland that
he should be treated otherwise this
matter should be resolved by the
judgement of his equals in our court all
these customs and liberties that we have
granted shall be observed in our kingdom
insofar as concerns our own relations
with our subjects let all men of our
kingdom whether clergy or laymen observe
them similarly in their relations with
their own men since we have granted all
these things for God for the better
ordering of our kingdom and to allay the
discord that has arisen between us and
our barons and since we desire that they
shall be enjoyed in their entirety with
a lasting strength forever we give and
grant to the Barons the following
security the Barons shall elect 25 of
their number to keep and cause to be
observed with all their might the peace
and liberties granted and confirmed to
them by this charter if we our chief
justice our officials or any of our
servants offend in any respect against
any man or transgress any of the
articles of the peace of this security
and the offence is made known to four of
the said twenty-five barons they shall
come to us and in our absence from the
kingdom to the chief justice to declare
it and claim immediate redress if we or
in our absence abroad the chief justice
make no redress within 40 days reckoning
from the day on which the offence was
declared to us or to him the four barons
shall refer the matter to the rest of
the twenty-five barons who made a strain
upon and to save us in every way
possible with the support of the whole
community of the land by seizing our
castles lands possessions or anything
else saving only our own person and
those of the Queen and our children
until they have secured such redress as
they have determined upon
having secured the redress they may then
resume their normal obedience to us any
man who so desires may take an oath to
obey the commands of the twenty-five
barons for the achievements of these
ends and to join with them in assailing
us to the utmost of his power we give
public and free permission to take this
oath to any man who so desires and at no
time will we prohibit any man from
taking it indeed we will compel any of
our subjects who are unwilling to take
it to swear it at our command if one of
the twenty-five barons dies or leaves
the country or is prevented in any other
way from discharging his duties the rest
of them shall choose another baron in
his place at their discretion who shall
be duly sworn in as they were in the
event of disagreement among the
twenty-five barons or in any matter
referred to them for decision the
verdict of the majority present shall
have the same validity as a unanimous
verdict of the whole twenty-five whether
these were all present or some of these
summoned who are unwilling or unable to
appear the twenty-five barons shall
swear to obey all the above articles
faithfully and shall cause them to be
obeyed by others to the best of their
power we will not seek to procure from
any one either by our own efforts or
those of a third party anything by which
any part of these concessions or
liberties might be revoked or diminished
should such a thing be procured it shall
be null and void and we will at no time
make use of it either ourselves or
through a third party
we have remitted and pardoned fully to
all men any ill will hurt or grudges
that have arisen between us and our
subjects whether clergy or laymen since
the beginning of the dispute we have an
addition remitted fully and for our own
part have also pardoned to all clergy
and laymen any offences committed as a
result of the said dispute between
Easter in the sixteenth year of our
reign and the restoration of peace in
addition we have caused letters patent
to be made to the Barons bearing witness
to the security and to the concessions
set out above over the seals of Stephen
Archbishop of Canterbury
Henry Archbishop of Dublin the other
bishops named above and master pandulf
it is accordingly our wish in command
that the English church shall be free
and that men in our kingdom shall have
and keep all these liberties rights and
concessions well and peaceably in their
fullness and entirety for them and their
heirs of us and our heirs in all things
and all places forever both we and the
Barons have sworn that all this shall be
observed in good faith and without
deceit witness the aforementioned people
and many others given by our hand in the
meadow that is called runnymede between
Windsor and Staines on the fifteenth day
of June in the 17th year of our reign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you